lo que tenemos aquí son algunas
preguntas de análisis de datos en un
contexto de biología del examen de
regentes de nueva york'
pero estos son ejemplos útiles si estás
estudiando biología en la escuela
secundaria en general porque pueden
aparecer en algún tipo de examen que te
aplique tu maestro o podrías verlos en
un examen estandarizado un estudiante
propone que si los voluntarios que
alientan antes de apretar una pinza para
la ropa durante un minuto
aumentarán la cantidad de veces que
puedan apretarla sin cansarse él afirma
que esto se debe a que sus músculos
estarán mejor preparados para el
ejercicio los datos de un experimento se
muestran en la tabla de datos a
continuación que prueba de la tabla
anterior proporciona los mejores datos
para respaldar su afirmación justifica
tu respuesta pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo entonces asegurémonos de
entender lo que está pasando aquí de
modo que hay dos pruebas esta es la
primera prueba la prueba 1 justo aquí y
en la primera prueba
dos grupos de diez estudiantes uno de
ellos hizo el calentamiento y los otros
diez no calentaron y luego en la prueba
dos tienes dos grupos más esta vez son
grupos de 25 una vez más 25 hicieron el
calentamiento y 25 no calentaron ahora
en la primera prueba el grupo que hizo
el calentamiento en realidad tuvo un
menor número de compresiones promedio
por lo que esto va en contra de la
hipótesis que tenía el estudiante la
hipótesis que tiene el estudiante es que
si calientan de antemano podrían hacer
más compresiones entonces la prueba uno
en realidad va en contra de la
afirmación del estudiante la segunda
prueba parece ir ligeramente a favor de
la afirmación del estudiante el grupo
que hizo el calentamiento pudo ganar
algunas compresiones más
ahora no hemos hecho el análisis
estadístico para saber qué tan probable
es esto si fue por pura casualidad pero
solo para responder la pregunta según
los datos la prueba uno va un poco en
contra de la afirmación del alumno la
prueba 2 respalda mejor esta afirmación
aunque no lo hace tan fuertemente
entonces yo diría la prueba 2 porque los
25 que calentaron es decir el grupo 3
grupo 3
pudieron en promedio en promedio apretar
más en un minuto que el grupo 4 que no
se preparó
muy bien hagamos otra pregunta entonces
aquí nos dicen se les pidió a los
estudiantes que diseñaron un experimento
de laboratorio que investigara la
relación entre el ejercicio y la
frecuencia cardíaca la frecuencia
cardíaca se determinó registrando la
frecuencia del pulso en latidos por
minuto
los estudiantes formularon una hipótesis
la cual dice que el aumento del
ejercicio da como resultado un aumento
del ritmo cardíaco los resultados de la
clase para el experimento se muestran en
la gráfica siguiente y luego nos dicen
qué enunciado es el mejor respaldado por
esta gráfica y tenemos cuatro opciones
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
muy bien vamos a revisar enunciado por
enunciado enunciado 1 antes del
ejercicio la frecuencia promedio del
pulso era 60 y 54 minutos después del
ejercicio
la frecuencia promedio del pulso era de
65 entonces veamos antes del ejercicio
la frecuencia promedio del pulso era
35 entonces antes de hacer ejercicio
este es un periodo de tiempo que tenemos
aquí y se ve como la mayor parte de ese
periodo de tiempo déjenme hacer esto en
rojo eso es más o menos cierto parece
que el pulso promedio era de 65 pero
leamos la segunda parte del enunciado
cuatro minutos después del ejercicio
la frecuencia promedio del pulso era de
65 también 4 minutos después de hacer
ejercicio cuál era la frecuencia
promedio del pulso bueno seguro que no
era 65 se ve más cerca de 135 tal vez no
65 así que podemos descartar está
después de 4 minutos de hacer ejercicio
la frecuencia promedio del pulso era de
120 vamos a ver de modo que aquí es
donde empieza el ejercicio después de 4
minutos
la frecuencia promedio del pulso era de
120 no parece que era como de 135 o algo
así esto se ve sospechoso dos minutos
después del ejercicio la frecuencia
promedio del pulso
a 120 entonces dos minutos después de
hacer ejercicio
la frecuencia promedio del pulso en
realidad parece estar más cerca de 90
estas dos parecen sospechosas así que
voy a descartar las mientras se hace el
ejercicio la frecuencia promedio del
pulso más alta era de 150 antes de hacer
ejercicio
la frecuencia promedio del pulso era de
veamos mientras se hace el ejercicio la
frecuencia promedio del pulso sucede
aquí y sin duda parece que está muy
cerca de 150 así que esta parte se ve
bien antes de hacer ejercicio la
frecuencia promedio del pulso era de 65
ya hablamos anteriormente sobre el
periodo que tenemos aquí esta se ve bien
me gusta esta opción pero veamos la
cuarta opción dos minutos antes del
ejercicio la frecuencia promedio del
pulso era de 80 entonces dos minutos
antes del ejercicio este punto es donde
empieza el ejercicio y cada una de estas
marcas es un minuto así que dos minutos
antes la frecuencia promedio del pulso
no era 80
entonces esta es falsa después de dos
minutos la frecuencia promedio del pulso
era de 140 después de dos minutos la
frecuencia promedio del pulso tampoco
era 140 de modo que estos dos enunciados
no son correctos así que me gusta el
enunciado 3 que es el que parece que
está mejor respaldado por los datos que
están aquí hasta el próximo vídeo